[Music]
do you guys believe
in in raffles like do you feel like you
are you would win in a raffle so you're
down to like
oh i never win that show i never win but
no i never win but i believe really
i i do buy it but i never win the tv or
whatever the [ __ ]
no i have one one time only one time
it was like back in the day when
navigation units weren't normally always
in cars standard
it was like a garment yeah yeah yeah it
was like one of the best things i've
ever worn is like 100
worth yeah so sick this is like 2008.
okay then yeah yeah yeah yeah depends on
what kind of room you're still using map
quests and [ __ ]
yeah yeah your own uh directions that
was like 2003.
no i'm telling you in 2008. i was
literally printing the directory you
couldn't afford one of those things
gps you got to get a raffle ticket you
know i believe in like physical raffles
but the online [ __ ] i'm like i don't i
don't trust this
oh like a 50 50 at a basketball game or
something no like online ones where
they're like oh
tag your friends and you can win
whatever i'm like oh i don't trust this
oh those are for sure fake but if you
get a ticket like a ticket right yeah
yeah yeah and then you did a little bit
yeah how about bingo though someone
always wins on bingo
true you think those are fake not always
but then i believe i bet sometimes they
are they they for sure are fake they
have to be
because sometimes they'll like record
themselves putting the names into
whatever and they're like hit random
so i'm like okay cool i saw it yeah but
they just announced it sometimes i'm
like was that your friend
i don't know sometimes it is really
because i did a raffle once
like for my my instagram thing and like
we really did like print out
the names we put in a bowl like that's
cause you're responsible
and you're honest and then i was like
and there are honest people out there
but there's also
the other it's not dishonest it's just
shitty [ __ ]
yeah shady there's also shady [ __ ] out
there
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no no no but i like i
like the idea of raffles like the
lottery
i like the idea of them do you ever
participate oh actually we could get
into the lottery later because we have
some lottery
uh stories i always feel like i'm gonna
win huh i always feel like i'm gonna win
like every time i
put my name into like a raffle i already
see myself owning that thing
that's visualization he's manifesting
he's always like i have it
so what happens when you don't i get
really sad
that's why i don't win because i always
go i just lost three bucks
no because that scenario well obviously
both both of them don't work
as soon as they like announce another
name i'm like that guy's taking my thing
i already have that
that's what i have about gambling i
don't even get close
you know they go okay and the number is
zero and just you already hear like
oh oh one five three and there's like
four people three people two people and
there's people they're just screaming
mine the first number is always offered
in my mother
you know
[Laughter]
no for me whenever i try to participate
in raffles and stuff i'm always like
it's so stupid but i want it so bad
that i'm like oh i want it i want it and
then i try to convince myself like no
you don't want it because every time you
want it you don't win remember let's try
not wanting it so then i tried telling
myself like
this is stupid i don't [ __ ] i don't
even want that [ __ ] just lying to
yourself
i try so hard to lie to myself and then
and then you get it or you don't get no
uh i have one like
once probably i feel like i did i can't
remember what it was
obviously not satisfied yeah but no like
the most recent raffle that i
participated in i was in this like
like big ol event thing and they were
calling people's names so it wasn't a
number
and so i was doing that internally like
oh i really wanted okay no no
whatever like i don't care because they
were like actually like giving a ton of
gifts it was like a lot of winners in
this period of time
and so um the one time that i feel like
i got the closest to not
wanting it and not caring the girl next
to me won and i was like
oh my god you sent your energy right
there the luck
skipped you out by one person she was
right all your life
the spirit said oh it's like i think i'm
feeling it right here
uh tips that's not yeah yeah okay that's
it tiff wants it
y'all reading the wrapped up t i or
f her her last name did start with hey
and i was like
yeah and the thing she won was so
[ __ ] cute i wanted it so bad what was
it
it wasn't it was a disney thing uh it
was like these
teal disney ears like princess and they
came with the tiny little purse backpack
and like totally tiff and i didn't get
it
i know right anyway so this story here
though this
owner of a house in england
england england england wood
england england
oh england england wood oh man sideways
as i eat
that was so stupid okay
okay i feel like i had to translate it
twice
no this is this way anyway so
this house in england is that it has
been valued at more than 1.5 million
dollars
oh really is is being raffled
away what for free no the ticket cost
two dollars and fifty five cents each
that's practically free
yeah what is that free that's a lotto
though yeah that's it that's a lot so
if like what how many people you need
like uh
50 000 wait how much my mouth is all
[ __ ] up
people also buy more than one thing you
need that coffee i'll buy a thousand of
them they have like
ticket like how much is it to make a
million
how many people how many tickets need to
be sold how much was it two dollars
1.5 million worth and then like six
hundred thousand
six hundred thousand ticks yeah but like
even at that point though it's like
would you really buy like a thousand
tickets or is like the maths
already so it's such a small
denomination of two dollars and
would you just already be like even if i
had a thousand ticks in there that's all
luck so might as well just buy one
yeah that's my mentality i'm just like
listen you could buy
it as well like you could you could buy
900 000 tickets
and still not winning yeah but then
you'll lose yeah
so that's why i'd rather do the one
ticket method where i'm like but there's
the probability yeah
yeah but it increases your chances
because it's like it's like this right
like let's say you buy
um like 500 000 tickets
and and then that's you know almost a
million
and then you you win because you had so
many chances
but then you're also betting against the
last time you did a raffle and then the
last time
you did a raffle did you win or lose and
if you won last time you're most likely
going to lose this time that's true it
doesn't
work that way that is like that
because that's like when you got when
you get struck by lightning your chances
getting struck by lightning are
drastically decreased yeah but if you do
get hit again and [ __ ] god hatred they
work like but then that also makes your
rarity of human being
drastically increased lightning strikes
scars they look
sick have you seen the people that win
like
the state lotto two three times in a row
yeah that's crazy luck there was this
one story of this one person that
won in a two-week span like 10 times
what
yeah but they didn't get it it was like
a little like small town where did that
come from
you mean like a thousand dollars here
and there
it totaled like a hundred thousand
dollars or something but what is that
do you feel like your rug like your ruck
runs out
[ __ ] it good luck good luck
guys you rock bro
gotta go on a london day there was that
one guy back in the day where he
like did the math and he was like if i
buy every combination of a lotto ticket
i'll win yeah so he did that over and
over and over in like australia until
they made laws against it then they went
he went to the us and he did the same
thing
he wanted yeah then he did it for
several more years
and he and he won he's buying tickets
yeah
the the prize like money was greater
than the
combinations available so he bought
every number
yeah and and he won yeah so he just won
like time after investment yeah until
they made laws against it
[ __ ] that was us statistician
statistical guy
have you seen have you heard about like
all those like uh the things that
happened to people that like win
lotteries oh the lottery
yeah yeah suicide whatever those guys
[Music]
no one ever comes out good yeah i think
it's because when you're overnight
like you have access to the world you
can buy whatever the [ __ ] you want
it just magnifies the issues that you
have yeah you didn't earns it
i think also they don't talk about the
people who their lives were completely
normal
so true we only hear the stories of like
the really bad ones oh it's because
statistically
you don't have people that come out okay
like it's like a huge number of people
that get just
[ __ ] well if they don't die they
either go broke
or like they um yeah go through a lot of
pain like emotional pain there's also a
lot of like imagine right when you
suddenly have like
tens of millions of dollars right over
here
yes i'm trying to manifest no but really
actual like the concept of liquid cash
even if you don't have it
right all the friends and family members
that's another issue come out of the
world
yeah are suddenly like hey yo like i
haven't seen you in a long time man we
should connect you know what i mean like
imagine that but on like every scale
maybe even your closest friend might
just be like hey yo so i got this
business
proposition you know what i mean the
expectation because like you didn't earn
that [ __ ]
you know you won that so then like i i
heard
those types of situations get really
emotionally drained people get killed
and stuff
but anyway back to this story here so
[ __ ] those people so
this this is called a dream home prize
wrap prize draw raffle and
so the the proceeds from the ticket
sales are being donated
to these two different hospices and one
of them
cared for the owner's late father
and this other hospice cares for
children with
life shortening conditions did you like
that to move
it was good it's good so the price money
goes to helping
the needy yes that's nice and so people
who are dying they were saying that the
that this raffle was inspired by an
emergency appeal for donations to one of
those hospice
care places and because of kobit 19 so
then that's when the owner
says you know what i've owned this house
for
20 years there have been major
renovations that were completed in 2018
the house has been valued at 1.5 million
dollars i want to
give back and so that's the reason why
he's putting up
this house for the raffle oh wow that's
almost a castle
that's what a 1.3 million dollar could
get you
1.5 in england well it depends on where
in england england
near sussex england
my house that i rent
is way crummier than this [ __ ] that
shit's a [ __ ] vineyard dude
there's a [ __ ] watchtower oh yeah
yeah
there is they call it the tower no
they're talking they're talking about
this house back here
that makes more sense yeah so this is
like
well my [ __ ] place is valued at 1.3
million
and it's nothing like this la price is
just so angry
i am i'm i [ __ ] l.a dude i'm leaving
this game
it is cheaper in england nowhere in
california can you get
that house for that price hell no i bet
you can
you can't for like a monthly rent i'll
go to middle class 1.5 million monthly
yeah central california i
bet you can oh but look at how [ __ ]
beautiful that house is you don't get no
[ __ ]
cash look at these chairs those are
those are asian furniture store chairs
no they're saying that the house will be
delivered unfurnished but it will come
with all the home fixtures they're gonna
deliver
[Laughter]
they got an amazon primer that's a big
ass backyard dude
that's a forest the view the the view is
that the wall right there
[Music]
this house is [ __ ] 20 million dude
[ __ ] 10 15 to 20 something million
and then at that it wouldn't even look
this good either at that
no there'll be 20 homeless people on the
beach jacking off
oh my god chess was angry
yeah yeah he had almost you know jacking
off
in his visual website they do that
it's true though think about it dude you
get a [ __ ] house
on venice think about it on venice right
that shit's like
12 million dollars you go outside
there's someone walking around with a
heroin needle on their [ __ ] arm
wow that's true that's way that yeah
that is a little bit of a
less funny image than like 20 homeless
people checking check it out man
you know the office depot in little
tokyo yeah i seen
a guy take a [ __ ] on a sign there the
[ __ ] pull on the pole
he just got very he [ __ ] sandwiched
the pole
into his butt crack and he just [ __ ] on
it and you just see the [ __ ] sliding
down the back you were just
watching them this guy didn't even try
to hide
it was a game for him he wanted to like
i wonder if my poop is cut in half if
they poop
he was putting on his science hat bart
you couldn't relate he's trying to just
all right
dogs do or something you know yeah and
you get an apartment there it's a
million dollars and it's not even a
bedroom it's a studio apartment wow and
you walk downstairs and
there's a man taking a doo-doo on a pole
man
yeah there's four bedrooms three
with ensuite bathrooms what's
unsweetened
that ocean looks extremely cold because
it's uh the uk
so i don't i think that is kind of
laughable you know
and if it's not like really nice fine
ground sand and it's just like rocks
wait how many squares 3 000. that's
double the
size of my home wait it looks like
[ __ ] 20
3 000. yeah feet of accommodation
that's the house itself right yeah that
[ __ ] looks like
10 000 square feet that little building
in the back
i'm telling you that house looks way
bigger than 3
000 it does yeah and then entire third
floor is called an observatory
and that's uh it's one short flight of
stairs takes you to the property's
crowning glory the observatory
it's just really inefficiently built
it's like that giant observatory it's
just like one stairway there's no actual
real estate for anybody
[Laughter]
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got just kidding news
merch yep so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
you